so uh
right hope you are in the right room
let's start with
YC
well you want to program a microwave
oven or a smart light bulb C might be
the language or a pacemaker uh some
fancy breaking systems in a car if you
want to develop a programming language
or work on an operating
system uh
supercomputing uh guidance systems but
that goes into space and maybe you just
want the battery to last the whole
summer there are plenty of uses places
where you would like to use uh
C so my name is Ol M I'm here to give a
reintroduction to
c uh I did last year uh at NDC Tech town
I was teaching a two de introductory
course in
C um but I also did a 60 Minute session
called 42 Silly Ways to Say Hello Inc
and while working on that talk I
realized how much you can actually teach
by using simplified
examples and Skip kind of the boring
details and just go directly into the m
so I challenged myself um to try to cram
as much as possible of the essent stuff
into uh one hour presentation like this
so what you're seeing now is the
premiere uh it was finished around 3:00
last night um but I have been thinking
about it for a year so it's not rushed
in any way but uh the slides will be
rushed because I have 259 of
them um so let's start with a very
proper and educational
example um notice how we are checking
the return value from puts and then
accordingly communicate success or
failure back to the runtime environment
and when we compile and run this code of
course we will get
hello
so this is your
stuff and um the other files on the top
of your program in your translation unit
they are basically expanded textually by
the
pre-processor and uh here I extract
significant details from these two
libraries and the first we see here are
the macros and they are textually
substituted into your
code and uh here we see a so-called uh
uh declaration or a
prototype which is saying that there is
a function somewhere I don't know where
but it exists and the symbol the Linker
you can try to find that symbol and Link
into this program uh when you uh compile
and Link this uh
Snippets and in this case the function
is part of the standard
Library the external keyword is implicit
so it's usually skipped uh
um and uh let's just rewind a few slides
like the here and notice that of course
there are other Library functions you
can use as well and printf um which has
a returns also an integer but it returns
some different values instead of just
saying yes or no whether it succeeded uh
it will return the number of characters
it printed out
and this might lead you into something
like
this you want to be really really secure
and kind of check that yeah really
printing six characters and there are
applications where you need to check
everything and
see but it's very easy to be taken down
into a rabbit hole um and uh you you get
more kind of checking code than uh not
that actually functionality and C has a
limited and very weak error handling
system and that is one of the reasons
why you probably want to consider other
program
languages if you
can but as I said in the initially there
are places where C is still the dominant
language uh you can even go get into the
bizarre examples like this uh this is
inspired by some code that I found on on
a very serious uh website about C
program programming um but it's it's
kind of ridiculous because we are
checking the return code from printf and
doing all the work but we don't check
the return code from fprintf and and
other stuff so it's just it looks like
it's very serious and and uh and safe
but it
isn't and when it comes to C programming
you often have to just make a decision
that something is just working and if
you're in on a kind of a desktop
computer running Linux or or something
like like that you probably can it's a
fair assumption to say that standard out
is always working um at least for kind
of Snippets and toy examples like I'm
I'm doing here so I I claim that this is
a decent way of saying hello and uh I
even go further I go to this where I
removed the return um because since c99
that's 24 years ago uh C has guarantee
that if you drop out of main you will
get whatever the operating
system runtime environment expects for a
success so you will basically get exit
success this is the same as what C++
does uh and then you're not forced to
lie you're not forced to say yeah
success uh can silently drop out and and
get the default Behavior so this would
be a good start now you might find it a
bit inconsistent uh that um main says
it's returning an INT and it
doesn't but you just have to deal with
it there are plenty of them in C and and
if that is problematic then maybe C is
not your
language right um hello
hello oh where is my hello
oh
cing I need to start this one
again ah hello there it is all right now
to something completely
different um here we have some integers
uh variables uh also called integer
object of automatic storage duration and
we initialize them with a collection of
constants exod decimal decimal octal
character construct and escape sequence
um in the standard Library the put Shar
function uh that writes to standard out
or more
precisely the past in argument is
converted to assigned integer type
before they passed into the putar
function and where they will be
converted to an unsigned Char before
they are sent to standard out and then
putar will convert that unsigned Char
back to an integer and returning back to
the to the
Coler and the I eror is reporting by and
uh and of file constant and this results
of course in another
hello um we talked a lot about
conversions some about conversions
already there will be much more um here
we have a suite of uh unsigned integer
variables wide ones down to narrow ones
uh
typically and they are all silently
converted to a signed in before being
passed into pchar there is this is
absolutely house is supposed to work
silently converting between
types uh not giving any warnings uh you
can probably turn on some very strange
uh optional Flags but if you put on wall
and vextra and all of those kind of
things you will not get a warning about
narrowing of of variables and and
widening of
integers and also as you notice in the
comments here we the only we have
guaranteed about
is a minimum size of these variables it
doesn't say anything about the maximum
size it is possible and I've heard
about um computers that where everything
is an in where everything is 32 bit and
but not of course the long long which is
64bit even the Char is 64bit and no
32bit and and so on
uh and talking about uh
conversions also these signed the
unsigned integers they have a signed
counterpart
um the signed is implicit and the int
keyword can be uh dropped so very often
you will see them like
this they are also being converted into
uh and signed in before pass to to
char uh without going into further
details about it but interesting that uh
all the others they have assigned and
unsigned part the Char actually are
three different types you have the
unsigned Char and the signed Char they
can be used for small integers small
numbers and the Char is a separate type
that is ideal for well drum roll
characters yeah
that's the conversion Mayhem doesn't
stop here watch closely
now all of these variables will also
silently be converted to assigned int
before they are passed into
picture um and once again it's a feature
that's how C
works and C is a typical weak type uh
it's a statically typed language but
it's also a weak typed language uh C++
is trying to make it a bit stronger but
uh C++ is also a weekly type language
um all right now for something
completely
different here I created an array of uh
integers and print them out to standard
out in the regular way now let's look
into the details there before we do that
um the external keyword well we know
that one it's saying that the pchar is
defined somewhere else the static
keyword is kind of doing the opposite um
it's basically saying to the compiler
don't make this object available for
anyone else to use an extern and say can
find the symbol here so the a by using
stating in front there the a symbol will
will not be visible from another U
compilation unit translation unit an
object pile that wants to link with this
program here we are we are now going to
do a lot of pointer work so here we are
um first of all we the the array is
as soon as you start using it in an
expression it decays into a pointer so
what we're looking at here is that a has
decayed into a pointer that we are now D
referencing with the indirection
operator um and uh we get an H coming
out
here here we are using the subscript
operator AR subscript
operator which is basically just a
tactical convenient way of writing what
you see here now where you take the Base
address plus two and then you dreference
it
um to get uh the L
out now since addition is
commutative this also works of course 3
plus I and yeah probably I guess the
next step very useful for pub quiz
questions but uh this is perfectly fine
uh there isn't much use for this
construct um but I've seen it used
successfully a couple of times uh one
was in an audio codec where there was
this kind of clever way of looking up
which codec to use um it wasn't
necessary but it kind of looked okay but
in um you can also sometimes find them
in macros that triggers compilation
errors if um if you are using the
incorrect
type passed into the the the the
macro and uh finally I'll show an
example where we take kind of the
address of the third element add another
three to that and then they reference
it and we will continue with some
pointer uh
[Music]
gymnastics so here is
uh what we're doing here is basically to
take the address of this Phantom element
that is one
beyond the array this is a very common
technique uh everything in in C++ is
based on this when it comes to ranges
and iterators and and so on but it's
also something that we do in see all the
time um and there is a guarantee in the
standard there will it's always possible
to compute the address of the one Beyond
element in in a sequence like
this and then by doing that we can
use we can uher to the other elements uh
relatively so in this case the minus 6
element from the one Beyond Min - 5 -4
minus
3 and uh we
can here we are taking the pointer of
the minus 2 and then dereferencing it
and it gets even worse like the last
thing here um of course you wouldn't
write this
yourself but when you are using macros
uh or when you are using uh looking at
COD generated uh automatically for you
you sometimes get these kind of
constructs and it's useful to understand
what they are doing and the answer is
basically that uh the these two the D
reference and the address operator or
the IND
Direction and U address operator they're
canceling each other out so what you're
looking at at here is basically only
this
thing
right now do something completely
different
so here I I have um I'm repeatingly
using the pre-increment operator to
increase the index so that we can print
out all the elements in the
array
um notice that I'm using size
T it is possible to use an INT but it
will usually take you in the wrong
direction uh an INT is first of all int
is a signed type you probably want to
use an unsigned type to in index into an
array unless
you're going negative in the array but
also the
size the width of the the type you want
to use to index into an array is um
machine dependent and the runtime
dependent so it's better to include St
Def and then you will get a type def for
size T that will typically give you an
unsigned int or an unsigned long or an
unsigned long long depending on what you
uh machine you are running on and it
solves a lot of portability issues so if
you have had problems porting between
32bit and
64bit um this might be one of the things
you have been struggling with uh in your
code but size T is your friend there is
also an s siiz t which can give you
assigned version of size
T so uh how are we going to deal with
this reputation any guess
H Loop yeah of course let's go for it
and uh yeah goto can do the job uh goto
exists in the language of see I had to
show it somewhere but also if you look
in the for example in the
Linux um kernel source code for Linux
kernel which is by the way one of the
best sources for learning uh C beautiful
beautiful beautiful code there um
you will find plenty of uses of goto
go-to is used all the time uh it's
usually not used like this though uh
it's mostly used to jump forward to
clean up things but you can also find
examples where you look at it and
said this seems to express the idea best
and uh why not use it I'm not
encouraging anyone to start using goto
massively but it's nice to know it
exists in the language the key reason
why I show it here is to give a buildup
onto the next the other ways of
iterating
trait one of the key kind of inventions
or concept features that c introduced
back in the early ' 70s was something
called the compound
statement so here again is referring to
putar because that's the one statement
but here the again label is bound to the
compound statement we have grouped
statements together and in C nearly
everywhere you you you can use a single
statement you can always put a compound
statement
instead by grouping them together with
the color braces like this now let's fix
the
indentation a bit and now you might
recognize there something similar
something that I recognized here yes
it's the do while loop so this is the
transition into the do while loop and
there is also a while loop where we put
the loop invariant on
top and now we recognize a pattern that
happens so often that there is a
separate keyword and a loop construct in
in C and lot of other languages and it
works like
this so the four
statements the middle part of that one
is the con is the loop condition same as
the wir is using and now I have just
left some open holes where we are going
that we are now going to fill with the
initialization of the loop variable and
with the update statement like
this and the for loop I show you now and
the Y Loop we had earlier they are
exactly the same they will probably
produce exactly the same machine code
well I'm quite sure they will produce
the same machine code they are
equivalent um here we are have hardcoded
six uh
elements um but it is possible to
compute the size of an array and this is
a an idiomatic way of doing
it where we take the size of the whole
array and then divide it by the size of
of the first element and that will give
you the number of elements
inside uh so in this case
um we can now change the size of the
array and the loop will still
work um the compiler knows how to count
you don't have to specify the size like
this you can leave it blank and then the
compiler will say yeah there are six
initialization elements here uh so
therefore I will create an array of uh
six
integers in this
case there are some useful functionality
in the main now so let's extract it into
a
function like this my put chars that
takes a base pointer and the number of
elements and then use the traditional
way of looping through every element
from the beginning to the
end and you can see down here that we
are passing in this one now a is used as
uh in an expression because this is
evaluated as an expression so it will
Decay to a pointer and that is what we
are passing in here and N is passed in
there inside this function there is
another way of iterating uh some people
call it iterator
pattern very much used in Plus+ and that
is instead of having a base pointer and
then index into each element we compute
the beginning of the sequence a pointer
to the beginning and then we
compute the address to the Phantom
element the one
Beyond and in the loop now we are
basically starting with the pointer to
the beginning and as long as the point
the iterated pointer is not the same as
the end we are doing this Loop over and
over and over
again and uh it's it's of course used in
C as well and has been used from the
very beginning of C but it's it's
everything in C++ is basically iterating
like this ranges and and so on so
inspired by C++ um you might say but um
it's it's a useful way to think about
iteration as well now um these begin and
end of course they can be passed in as
argument arguments like
this um so now the caller basically
sends in the base uh pointer to the base
and then the pointer to the one
beyond all right but now we instead of
giving the beginning and the end or the
number of elements we might introduce a
convention that says if there is a zero
in the end of the array then you should
stop
iteration and we can now change this uh
loop condition so that we dreference the
iterator and check that it's not zero as
long as it's not zero we are just
iterating over and
over now this is the same as this and be
like T concise uh small code so it's
often written like
this and now we don't need the end uh
pointer anymore we can just pass in the
base of the array and it will Loop until
um the zero uh element uh in this
array and now we can get rid of the size
calculation as well like this
now here we pass in the beginning and we
create an iterator why not just take it
in as an
iterator and similarly here we using the
pre-increment which you should always
default to the pre-increment for some
reason C programmers tend to default to
the post
increment um I think we should do some
work on on convincing to to by default
use the pre-increment but this is a
particular case Cas where if you move if
you put the post increments here we
don't need the updates u in in the
followup anymore and now we are
recognizing that this is basically a y
Loop and
uh
um it's probably time to reveal what
these numbers are
uh so I change it to a Char and then I
use uh kind of a constant literal uh
instead oh sorry character literals
instead uh and what you're looking at
now is exactly the same as
this so the string representation is
basically a nice way of saying exactly
this it's just more compact than uh than
all the braces and all the comment and
and so
on and implicitly you will get a zero in
the end always when you use a string
literal like
this now if we continue to make it more
and more similar to
puts uh we just uh add a new line in the
end so we don't need to have it in our
string
literal and then we can change it to my
puts and if we also now change the it to
the more common s which is often used in
King and Richie and the library and so
on we realize that we have basically
created puts but without returning the
returning an error
condition and of course we can put the
literal inside the call and let's just
go for puts anyway and we can get rid of
this one and we have a nice hello oh
before that yes we have an include that
we don't need we have had it for a few
slides remember to clean up your code
get rid of the unnecessary includes uh
there was it's it's quite common when
you look at really large code bases that
half of the compilation time is actually
opening and closing files to be
included so uh a very good advice for
anyone working with a large code base is
to look at how you can get rid
of unnecessary includes and how you can
avoid header files to be included over
and over and over and over again and
there is something called an include uh
macro guard at you can use to avoid that
and and so on also pragma ones is
sometimes used but anyway let's clean up
and we have a nice hello
again all
right now to something completely
different I like
cooking and I take it seriously I'm not
very good at it but i' still take it
seriously um and here are some notes I
made while uh doing a 1.3 kilo steak in
oven at
125 Celsius so I just used them as as an
excuse for
creating a structure with a Time Temp
and scale because sometimes I
accidentally hit the button on
the on the St Thom and uh I end up with
the Fahrenheit instead of Celsius and I
have to fix that but this example I just
let the fahrenheit be
here so when you run this
code here is the structure here is an
array of these uh structures initialize
and when I here I compute the number of
samples observations and here I just
have a pretty print of the time the temp
and the scale and uh this is the output
of this
program I need the screen estate here so
I just put them on one line even though
I don't do that in practice but I just
need more lines on the slide
here so looking at this Loop here um
this is just a an excuse for showing two
constructs continue and
break and suppose that if the scale is
not not Celsius then I don't care about
it so I say continue and that means go
back and do the do the next operation um
the the next
iteration similarly if the time is more
than 131 that's 2 hours and 11 minutes I
took the stake out there are still
observations but I don't care about them
uh you might say let's just
break the the iteration I'm not
interested anymore
so this was just an excuse to show
continue and break but there is a
warning here though uh continue and
break well continue in particular they
are like
um uh bug
attractors very often when you have bug
in in the code it's close to a continue
used in the most simple scenarios like
this it's probably fine but in your code
base you should probably do a search for
continue
uh and and read the code around it and
you have a high chance of finding a bug
because it breaks the logic it breaks
the thinking both for the computer and
and for the compiler no for the
programmer uh and it's it's often a good
idea to be careful about using continue
used like this I think it's fine but
more complicated examples are often not
fine they can be solved in different
ways uh um yeah so this is the output we
get when we have done the continue and
break now I need to rewind a bit
simplify the slides to fit more into
them so
I'm simplifying this back to what we
had I'm also just getting rid of a few
observations uh to get a few more lines
to work
with
um sometimes when I do these
observations uh I get them in the wrong
order I might write them on a different
note and and so on so here just to
illustrate that I swwa these two
observations so they are not in timely
order of course I could have sorted them
and do all of that kind of stuff but now
it's a nice chance to show this one and
this doesn't exist in
C++ well it maybe it came in C++
20 you can do this
um you can specify which element you
want to initialize in in the sequence
now in the in the array and you can also
use these names to say these are the
elements I want to initialize and they
can you can swap the order and and and
things like that sometimes this is super
convenient this is called
designators and they provide explicit
initialization uh in in a list like
this
desate
initializers
yeah all right slightly changing we are
still working with the temperature here
but not with an array we are now now
introducing a
compound um
literal so here I'm basically creating
an object
object as I'm passing it into the print
sample function and the print sample
function is taking a copy of that object
that we can work with inside of the
function um this might I've seen
examples or heard and and heard about
examples of um using this as kind of a
poor man kind of named
arguments way of passing named arguments
into a function I'm not sure how far you
should go down into that route but um I
guess you see that it's a possibility of
of doing
so all right so this will print out a
temperature
now we might instead of passing a copy
of the whole structure we might want to
just pass uh a pointer to that structure
by the way in in
C uh you can only pass by copy there is
no such thing as pass by reference and
even pointers are passed by copy because
they are Pointers that you are actually
passing so you might pretend like it's
something more advanced but it's still a
pass by copy so this is also a pass by
copy we are copying in the pointer to
this object in this case it won't save
as much performance actually it might be
much worse um but uh it's quite common
to work on on pointers instead of uh big
uh structures that we are copying back
and forth uh into functions in
C um notice that since we are passing a
pointer we need to D reference the
pointer before we can access the element
inside of the structure so that's what
we are doing here now this has
um a nice
syntactical um helper with this Arrow um
operator also called the structure Point
operator um but it's useful to know that
what you're looking at here is the same
as we see
here um since we are not modifying the
object that we are
receiving you probably want to to put a
const in front and const is just as
important in C as it is in
C++ so whenever you're working where you
have a pointer to an object and you do
not intend to change it you probably
want to declare it as const it's a very
strong communication tool to other
programmers and yourself and the
compiler um that this
is you're sending in some data but
you're not giving away the ownership to
it
and you're not allowing modification on
on the on the
data and here I call it print sample
print sample is a perfectly fine
function name uh for this but it's quite
common to see this naming um standard or
whatever where the first part of of the
function is basically the structure name
and the last part is kind of
the member function accessing and and
using that structure and by doing this
you get some kind of feeling that we can
do some objectoriented stuff
uh I would say there you you can't
really do that I have seen so many
efforts of trying to do object
orientation in C and uh when I see the
horrors of the result I always recommend
why not use C++ instead if you want to
go deep down in the objectoriented uh
way C++ is pro probably your language
instead but anyway it's very common to
see see something like
this um and you can take this ID further
um so here I've implemented not a
command member member function but a
query member function uh where you pass
in the temp pointer to a temp sample uh
structure and then you query can I get
the temperature in celsius
please and inside here you're Computing
um doing what is needed to always return
the Celsius version of the temperature
in that
observation this gave me a chance to
show the if and the elif and and so on
but what I really wanted to show was
this
this would be a typical example where we
would use switch and
case
um the switch
um is must be um well typically it's
it's a numerical uh value that's uh you
can uh then make a decision should I go
to this case this case or these cases
notice
that um
here we have a fault
through from R to K and I claim that
this is a perfect example and why switch
is so nice you really want that F
through uh and it's so obvious that you
don't probably don't want to document it
with a this kind of pman annotation by
the way this annotation is the formally
defined in the c23 standard then it
comes with square brackets and and so on
but uh you get full through but be aware
that every case that you don't want to
full through on you of course you need
the break and I realize now you probably
need a you want a break here as well on
the default just for consistency in case
you decide that the default should be a
case instead of the default and and so
on I I don't
know all right I got the chance to show
the switch and
case um before moving
on here we are using a character to um
to hold the scale whether it's Celsius
Fahrenheit Rankin or kelvin um but you
could also introduce an
enom um with a temperature scale uh it's
a fair primitive mechanism the enom in
in
C mostly is a bit like creating just
const
um you can wrap the enm inside of a type
no inside of a struct and somehow
emulate enms that are type safe and so
on um it takes you a bit in the right
direction but not all the way it's a
primitive mechanism but it's very useful
um and and for example this is a decent
example of using enms in C enms are are
usually stored as an integer maybe
that's defined in the standard in C++ uh
the standard says just the number of
bits required to store the enom which is
usually if you have less than 256 cases
it's usually a
bite or a Char a
Char all right now to something
completely
different so here I want to um talk
about uh storage duration memory and and
how we deal with
that uh what we you are looking at now
is
um we are creating a
sample which is at so called object of
automatic storage duration some people
call it a function
variable or a stack variable uh I don't
like those names especially not the last
one stack variable because it kind of
implies that c has a stack and
theoretically it does but in practice
the compiler will try to avoid using a
stack as much as possible um so if
you're looking for a stack inside of the
produced machine code you will often not
find the stack in C and in the C
standard the word stack is never
mentioned um in the standard um so um
it's a long it's it's a long word
automatic storage duration but it's
useful word to use because if you search
on the internet and you have questions
about it if you sear search a stack
variable you will get to thousands and
thousands of recommendations for how to
do things written by people that don't
understand much about C if you search
for automatic storage duration you won't
get that many hits but they are probably
of a higher quality than kind of the
stack variable people
uh the scope is also interesting here um
the scope of
sample is within this function
demo um of course try to avoid um using
Global scope we often want to limit the
scope of our symbols as much as possible
that's also the reason why we tend to
put static in front of things to limit
the kind of linker visibility where can
this will be seen uh and the same is is
through here it's um the scope of sample
is it's not visible outside of this
F now if I take
this object of automatic uh storage
duration and then move it out into the
file
level I
get an object of static storage
duration um
so every object uh defined in the file
on the file level they are by default
implicitly stat static so adding static
in front it's the same keyword and to my
surprise it is actually in the standard
it is called the
storage um specifier also when used like
this um but it's it's an overloading
both of the keyword and intention of it
because as you know U we talked about
what it's doing is reducing the Linker
visibility other object files cannot see
uh the sample uh now that we have static
in
front all right let's move it back into
the function but now using the static
keyword
here static means something else now
static means that the object well I
forgot to say that let's go back um the
objects of automatic storage duration
starts to exist on the beginning of the
function and it is
destroyed when you go out of the
function it well it isn't destroyed as
such it's not valid anymore so if you
reference uh refer into it you get
undefined Behavior so in practice it
doesn't exist however if you put it
uh objects of static storage duration
like this they are created before
Main and they stop existing after main
is
finished and the same is true also if
you put them inside of this function so
the object is now created before Main
and allocated and and and ready before
Main and certainly before you come to
demo and it will exist until the program
terminates this also mean you can
return um a pointer to it so here I'm
taking the address of this um object of
static storage duration and return it
back to main so that main can print out
the sample uh and this is about dealing
with the ownership and so on I'm not
saying that this is necessarily a good
idea but it's not necessarily a bad idea
either it's something that you can do
because the object exists it has static
sour duration exists from the beginning
to the end of the
program or storage for that object
exists now the obvious next thing to
show is using
maloc which is an object
of correct me allocated storage
duration Dynamic storage duration
yes um
so yeah but I think this is in C it's a
dynamic stor verion but this needs to be
checked but anyway U Malo so Malo is a
way to ask uh usually the Heap even
though that doesn't exist either in in
the theory in practice it does um so it
asks for some memory in the free store
um and it will return a pointer to it if
it succeeds or null if it doesn't exceed
and if you can't get memory to work with
you probably don't want to continue your
program so exit failure is might be what
you want to do or somehow violently
scream I'm not ready to
continue uh you certainly don't want to
ignore it because writing into a memory
location that uh you were not
given or null for example it's it's a
terrible ID uh don't do
it and uh now since we have um an object
of dynamic storage duration we can do
whatever we want it will exist until we
release it with a
free so you can choose to do it in the
same place or you can create it one
place and then say well I will delete it
later and so on this is perfectly fine
it's something that we often do with uh
dynamically allocated
memory um but of course you might
want I I would like to show an example
where we do the maloc and the free in
the same function so I'm moving it in
here now Malo is there is there I'm we
printing out the sample and it gives me
a chance to show the more typical use of
a goto uh it very often looks like this
so you have some cleanup section in your
function and then if you get some errors
after having grabbed some resources and
allocated some memory you go to the
cleanup section and and you get rid of
your
stuff now this can always be solved with
an extra of in
Direction um
so it is a choice you have whether you
want to use go to like this or not but
uh sometimes you're in a situation where
you don't write all the code yourself
sometimes you just have to deal with
code written by others and then it's
useful to understand this particular
idiom I think I counted more than 100
uses of this in the Linux colel uh it's
a very common way of doing it there
there for example
layer H layer yeah and yeah you can also
layer them yeah all
right we are doing nice on time here um
we need to talk about memory a
bit
[Music]
um on my development PC the one I'm
writing my slides on um often I work in
an embedded domain and then this isn't
true at all but on kind of a desktop
computer
um and on my PowerPoint generating
machine uh I get uh if I run this
program my ins are four in
size
my double is
eight Char is one that is actually the
only value that you know is always one
the others they can vary they can be the
integer can be four it can be eight it
can be two it can be
one someone wants to correct me yeah
one it will probably be one if the Char
is
one no if yeah if the Char is 32
bit uh then the integer can be one so
theoretically you don't know how big it
is but then you might be a bit surprised
by the size of the structure it's
24 and to encourage some interaction
anyone would like to suggest
why yeah all right
you H
sorry yes it's alignment and I like that
you said alignment first you said
padding because uh if it's not because
of the padding that we get it it's
because of the
alignment that we get this uh this size
and the thing is that stuff like double
and int they often want a certain
alignment uh and on my machine if the
compiler puts a double onto an address
that is not divisible by
eight I get an the program crashes
uh it's often a segmentation fault or
something like that that it ends up with
similarly if the int is put on an
address that is not divisible by
four it
crashes the Char is the only one on my
machine that you can put anywhere you
want so these structures they come with
an alignment
requirement and the rule of thumb is
approximately like this the alignment
requirement M of a struct will typically
be the same as the Align requirement of
the
strictest um element
inside which in this case is
eight 24 is divisible by 8 so that's the
reason why we get 24 and then the
compiler will do what it takes to kind
of pad up the others so that they are
correctly uh put in
place um yeah I remove that slide but
there is actually
um a keyword in C called align
off uh where you can ask the object and
the type what's what is your alignment
requirement
yeah on my machine that's correct yes so
um uh what the gentleman over here said
is that if you change the or order of
this particular structure on my machine
which is probably very similar to yours
since you knew that um then uh then the
int which has an alignment requirement
of four um the Char can be wherever so
it can take one of the otherwise padded
spaces and then the double will get uh
an aligned eight
um mod 8 uh address position
uh and then the whole struct will get an
alignment requirement of 16 well of
eight it's still alignment requirement
of eight but the size will be uh 16 on
my development my PowerPoint generating
machine on embedded it's completely
different you have to study the ab ABI
abstract binary interface that tells you
about the alignment
required all right and
then the final
example and I have shown this many times
in talks before so some of you might be
like oh not again but if you haven't
seen it before you might
enjoy or be scared to death by this
one uh this is a piece of code that is
um of course it's
rubbish um but it's you can type it into
Java or into sharp or a lot of other
program languages and it will always
generate exactly the same result it's
well defined in many other languages but
not so in C not so in
C++ spend a few seconds just look at it
try to figure out what do you think it
might
be on my machine well you can give or
you can what would it be on your machine
or your kind of chip when you are doing
some embedded development and so on and
uh I take some anyone that would like to
suggest we will come maybe come back to
that
yeah all right who wants to make a first
guess yes thank you 13 I love that
answer any anyone else zero zero I love
that answer as well come on
any higher
lower well the point here is and this is
super important and it's true in C++
it's true in C and that is the
evaluation order is mostly
unspecified we don't know we cannot know
whether it's trying to evaluate
expressions from left to
right if it's a strictly left to right I
think you get
11 if you do a strictly right to to left
you get something
else if you do kind of a spiral
evaluation you get something
else but what compilers often do is that
say I I don't care because this is a
sequence Point violation you are not
allowed to up update a variable twice
within a sequence point and um and that
the sequence points are basically The
rhythms in the program that says when do
these evaluations have to be stored into
some place so that it can be used for
other Evolutions
later in uh in more modern standards
it's called sequence before and sequence
after and so on but the the rules are
approximately the same so since we don't
know the evaluation order if if we
evaluate this one first and then this
one and this one we get one result if we
one and this one we get another
result and uh here are three compilers
the GC compiler will give you
12 the Intel compiler will give you
13 and Clank will give you
11 no on average they
are well they are all
wrong so by that thank you very much
that was my
talk we we have room for couple of
questions um or comments or
whatever if there
are no or I will hang around here and
you can uh you can discuss this anytime
and I plan to
publish these uh
slides uh I just need to put on some
talking Bubbles and and so on so that
it's possible to read them without the
narration of me uh and I will also add a
few extra things there because then I'm
not limited to 60 minutes then I can do
maybe 90 minutes when I present the
slides yeah there is one question over
there I will repeat the question oh yes
go for it is it possible to find out the
maximum value of of a size T typed uh
variable yeah it's uh in limits.
ag uh you can you can find uh the limits
of uh of the types so just as you can
find the biggest inss or the biggest
unsigned Longs and and so on uh I'm
quite sure you can find the maximum size
of of uh size t as
well yeah
any
other over here
yeah
microphone yeah but it needs to be on
the recording so doesn't C++ from 17
specify the evaluation order of
operators um which would sequence this
right I I'm quite sure it didn't make it
into
17 because then I think I would known
okay I followed uh I followed C++ until
17 and uh now I don't follow it very
closely anymore but uh they are working
actively on the evaluation order I'm not
sure if they do it on the Expressions if
that is their intention uh like this but
they are certainly doing it on the
evaluation order on the on the function
arguments and so on so typically GCC
will go backwards on the function
arguments arguments you pass into a
function will typically be evaluated
from right to left on GCC and left to
right on other compilers and some just
do it in a random
order but the evaluation order is one of
the sources of a lot of kind of
interesting behavior in in CN C++
yeah all right enjoy the conference and
uh yeah that was it
thanks